hey guys merry and Alexa in Tokyo 40 GS
2016 and we just got finished playing
area X which is the new area in res now
you guys are going to see us wearing the
VR headsets because we played it in BR
and this game is actually available in
both VR and you don't have to have it
you can just play it at this we're going
to show you gameplay from full screen
version a lot of people when they play
VR games they do have problems of motion
sickness Alexa you've actually been
notorious for getting a little sick when
he play their games how did this one
fair ya know I go to bar town right away
and when I was playing res infinite I
actually yeah i did get stick at all and
you would think like in normal res i
sort of would get a not queasy but i
would definitely feel a little
uncomfortable with nothing terrible and
when I went to play area X I was
thinking oh it's off the rails I'm
flying around I'm gonna be either using
my head a lot I didn't get stick at all
there's no horizon line they've removed
sort of all of the all of the things
that indicate to your brain I'm moving
and it was a really comfortable
experience for me so I definitely
suppose it's incredible when you think
of a VR title that they kind of have to
make a game for VR because it's such a
unique experience but res smooths into
VR pretty easy it's already third person
it's already this open environment that
sound based and it kind of seems like
it's just a good system to go into VR
but even if you don't play in VR this is
a really nice next step for the series
of res when you say yeah it feels like
the natural evolution of the series I
did speak with two team is a Gucci and
he mentioned that when he first came up
with res in his head he thought of I
want this in BR so when they announced
it back at PlayStation experience
everyone was like super surprised like
oh resin be our people you know still
love res and it was a surprise to see it
come back with something new
and having played it in VR having played
the new area X and V are where again
you're just off the rails do whatever
you want on your own pace you can fly
around we could only focus on enemies
and do it everyone it feels like the
natural evolution of res and it feels
like definitely one of the more
comfortable VR experiences with iPad
up till now I've ever really been sold
on VR like oh here's gimmick but this is
the game that really did it for me I
think having just those 20 minutes to
just fly rest yeah i agree looks like
you and I have done so many VR demos in
my time and not just in like sony BR but
like vibe or there's so many different
things that we've played there are
certain games that can sell VR this is
one of those experiences that makes you
feel like that this really is the future
it's the perfect time for VR where it's
not making people queasy as much and is
that you know the technology is there
and then this game is like chocolate and
peanut butter it's like really kind of
combining those two elements in a good
way but again even without VR would you
say that area ex kind of really helps
convey the new area of Reds infinite and
just like what this experiences for
people for fans of the series I really
think that if everyone who's played res
has thought about you know what I'm not
on the whales res has always been on
Rails I feel like taking off the rails
was the natural next step and I don't
know having it in VR like seeing it not
in dr's like really cool too and it's
really excellent but like I had a really
emotional experience playing it BR like
I was just thrilled like I played
standing I felt myself starting to dance
starting to move like really immersing
yeah playing it without VR I think you
can get sort of the same feelings from
it and play it the same way and still
enjoy it but like oh you gotta do the VR
got him in VR yeah this is like one of
those experiences that if you like had
everyone over and no one had BR before
we even had someone in our group who had
never done vr before and this was their
experience and it blew them away like
this is the next step for VR that's
gonna like really shake people and
realize that this is hardware that
people are going to start wanting but
again without it it's still a tremendous
Reds experience really great beats and
audio and such a visceral experience
with all the lights and colors and
there's a lot of Secrets the footage we
guy we can show you
actually is not fully into area X they
have a lot of surprises but some of that
area is stunning and it's just a truly
heartfelt experience I think it's
something that I'm really glad I tried
it sounds like you really mad at you yep
I'm so consoled
you